найбільша техногенна катастрофа у Європі
за останні десятиліття так офіційний
Київ називає знищення каховської ГЕС
якими будуть наслідки військові
гуманітарні екологічні далі у поясненні
ДВ
Гуманітарна катастрофа
80 населених пунктів опинилися в зоні
підтоплення це 17 тисяч людей на
Правобережжі яке контролює Україна 10
сіл і частина Херсона опинилися у воді
люди втратили житло а для багатьох
тварин вода стала смертельною пасткою
усе сиділа усе сподівалося що залишимося
а потім Як почала бігти вода з такою
силою Що
руськіни Мабуть підбили дамбу не
подумавши Як то кажуть вони не гуманні
їм нема пробачення ніяк абсолютно лівий
берег Дніпра окупований росіянами
географічно нижчий там наслідки зна
масштабніші Попри це як заявив президент
Зеленський російський окупанти повністю
провалили евакуацію людей звідти у
містах які брали воду з Каховського
водосховища ситуація теж складна зокрема
Кривий Ріг і окупований Бердянськ
втратили основне джерело води доля
криворізьких промислових підприємств а
також заводів у Нікополі Марганці і по
крові під питанням адже виробництво теж
залежить від води найбільшого удару
зазнало сільське господарство надто
овочівництво зрошення земель на півдні
залежало від Каховського водосховища
Тепер воно неможливе після повені тисячі
людей одразу стали біженцями згодом
через втрату роботи у промисловості і
сільському господарстві ще більше
мешканців Півдня України можуть залишити
регіон якими будуть наслідки для
тимчасово окупованого Росією Криму
прогнозувати складно Кримський канал
брав воду Московського водосховища
офіційний Київ Застерігає що півострів
може залишитися без води на роки Так
звана окупаційна адміністрація заявляє
що водосховище на півострові заповнені
більше ніж зазвичай і питної води людям
не бракує принаймні поки що
загроза для запорізької АЕС Запорізька
атомна електростанція яка перебуває в
окупації потребує води з Каховського
водосховища для охолодження нині ставок
охолоджувач АЕС заповнений але він
поступово випаровується Наразі у мегате
певні що у безпосередньою загрози для зс
поки немає
води основний - це велике
охолоджувальний ставок біля майданчика
розташований вище за рівень водосховища
оскільки реактору не працювали певний
час води для охолодження з цього ставка
Може вистачити на кілька місяців
в українському енергоатомі кажуть що
наповнити резервуар охолоджувач можна
зокрема з підземних свердловин
наслідки для довкілля
екологічні наслідки ка
тастрофи масового
знищ понад 150 тисяч тонн машинного
масла Потрапили у Дніпро витік може бути
ще більшим до того ж через підтоплення у
воді опиняються сміттєзвалище кладовище
промислові відходи екосистема яка
склалася у дельті Дніпра за 70 років
існування Каховського водосховища
назавжди зруйнована в
Lost National Park територія
національний природний парк
нижньодніпровський
частини смарагдової мережі про
одноохоронних територій європейського
значення
що певні ділянки дикої природи ми
втратили назавжди
Lost Forever крім того невідомо як
виглядатиме русло Дніпра надалі коли
вода спаде експерти кажуть що південь
України може перетворитися на пустелю
наслідки для контрнаступу у ГУР
Припускають що російські війська
підірвали греблю каховської ГЕС щоб
зупинити Контрнаступ ЗСУ водночас у
Міноборони кажуть що катастрофа не
вплине на їхні плани західні експерти
розглядають різні сценарії
що українці розглядали можливість
наступу через Дніпро в Херсонській
області та так але в іншому випадку це
анітрохи не завалить наступу майбутній
наступ схоже буде зосереджений на
Донеччині і Запоріжжі наразі ми бачимо
пробні атаки з метою перевірити
російську оборону
ці призведе до припинення постачання
прісної води до Криму що з одного боку
ускладнить роботу російської влади з
іншого боку це зруйнує електропостачання
створить гуманітарну катастрофу тому
виникне необхідність у переселенні людей
а оскільки територія контролюється
Росією це російських силовиків і можливо
змусить РФ перекинути сили в Нову
Каховку щоб упоратися з цим
Нова Каховка
коли вода піде на спад зокрема там де
недавно було водосховище рівень води
буде нижчим можливо протягом літа ці
землі підсохнуть складно прогнозувати
зміни на полі бою тож ми можемо говорити
лише В загальних термінах А ви ми знаємо
що українська армія краще
пристосовується до змін ніж російська
водночас Володимир Зеленський заявив
руйнування росіянами джерела води для
Криму означає що вони усвідомили
необхідність утечі з півострова про
можливість відновлення каховської ГЕС і
водосховища можна буде говорити лише
після звільнення цих територій